welcome everyone to
another topic on vmware tutorial for
beginners in this one we are going to
talk about like
what is the purpose of using a vmware
and how what are the different
benefits we get with this one here so
uh we will be talking about what is a
vmware all about
then vmware and virtualization and uh
the benefits and the introduction to
hypervisor then the components of
virtualization is
what exactly are the different
components which is available there
and then at last we will be creating a
virtual machine using the vmware
playstation
now what exactly is the need of vmware
now
vmware is a kind of virtualization
concept which is available there
so let's try to understand uh it with a
small story over here
so that we will be able to get a good
understanding about what is the overall
purpose of using a vmware here
now before the virtual machines or the
vmware uh i can use the terminology as
virtualization virtual machines vmware
they all
are pointing to the same point so let's
assume like we got a developer
who is uh working on the application and
the application is not working uh
is uh is not working as expected now it
could be like uh
due to the poor data recovery poor
maintenance poor performance
so the overall benefits or the overall
quality of the product which we
are expecting is not coming up over here
now um after the vmware what really
happened over here is like we
got a certain solutions you can use the
virtual machines to host your
applications the maintainers becomes a
little bit more easy and little bit
less cost effective so
we got like reduced uh operation
operating cost
we got like increased id productivity uh
efficiency and agility there
so we are trying to see like how exactly
uh we are performing the executions
we are performing uh the setup here so
we also got like a faster provisioning
of applications so that also something
we are
getting over here when we talk about
from the vmware so these are some couple
of benefits which we get
uh as a solution a complete full flash
uh solution from the vmware here
so these are the some solutions which
are talking about from the vmware
perspective
and uh it also helps us to go for a
greater business or continuity there
because it helps us to provide
a high level of virtual machines in case
an existing virtual machine gets deleted
we can get a new
one spinned up within just minutes of
time duration
um it helps us to go for a disaster
recovery like where we can go for a dr
kind of setup also
in addition to production and it also
helps us to go for an easy management of
the data center that's a biggest benefit
because
usually we have so many servers so many
infrastructure there
so if you really want to resolve if you
really want to maintain the things in a
much
easier way then vmware or virtualization
is a score for that
right so what is the relationship
between the vmware and the
virtualization here
now in simple terms vmware is something
which uh we can call it as a
virtualization software
uh this is something which we can use as
an virtualizer over here
so virtualization uh software is
something which generates
a kind of a virtual environment uh just
on top of an
uh physical infrastructure the main
focus of the virtualization is to
see like how we can create a virtual set
of resources
by consuming or by using the existing
resources the existing physical
resources
so in case of virtualization we can make
use of the elements
like ram memory storage and these can be
actually converted into the virtual
resources
so and then we can create a virtual
machines which will be consuming these
virtual resources
so that uh they will be able to uh get a
full-fledged environment up and running
so vmware is a kind of a tool which
provides us
a virtualization a software and
virtualization is a concept
in which we will be uh using or reusing
the existing physical infrastructure
in such a way that we will be able to uh
make a most out of our uh infrastructure
components so that's the main
uh component or main reason why we are
looking forward for
these kind of virtualization here right
now so what exactly is a hypervisor here
now hypervisor we talked about the
vmware we talked about virtualization
now hypervisor is a kind of uh tool
it's a kind of a management tool which
is available to manage the virtual
machines here
the main focus of hypervisor is to
manage like how the virtual machine can
be done
right so that's the main focus of a
particular hypervisor here
and if we talk about the uh mechanisms
like how
hypervisor is really going on there so
that's where we will be able to also
understand that
this is something which can take up the
request from the virtual machines
and uh then send it to the host
operating system or to the physical
infrastructure
so it acts like an intermediate between
the host operating system
and the virtual machine so as for this
diagram you can see like we got this
virtual one
virtual machine one virtual machine two
and virtual machine three
in virtual machine one you have the
applications you have the binaries you
have the libraries
you even have a guest operating system
in machine 2
you also have the application binaries
guest operating system
third also is having the same thing now
we also have a hypervisor in between the
physical infrastructure and the virtual
environment which actually
uh helps us as a kind of a layer which
will be doing the
collaboration between how exactly these
communication will be performed
and uh the overall uh communication or
the two info uh
request can be processed over here in
this case so this is something which we
will be uh really going to see like how
the overall uh setup and the overall
modifications can be already performed
here
so that's one of the mechanism which is
available there like how
we are going for this specific approach
over here
right so virtual machine
is a very important component because
the hypervisor is going to manage the
virtual machine only
and what we have into our virtual
machine so we basically have
a full-fledged environment you can talk
about like in that you have
a guest operating system you can have an
application running
libraries whatever things you want to
store you want to
deploy over there you can actually do it
so that's something we can easily get it
over here
with the help of this component so
virtual machine is something which is
really helping you to see like how
you can deploy a certain resources onto
this one
right so um it's it's a kind of a
virtual environment
so if you deploy it into a physical
machine or physical server
then we call it as an a kind of physical
machine
or server but right now it's actually
deployed onto a virtualization or a
virtual
environment that's why we call it as in
virtual machines because it's
not physically available it's a present
as an
onto a virtual machine here
right and whatever applications you feel
application binaries libraries whatever
those components you want to deploy
you can actually get those things
deployed as such on this one so that's
the main benefit
which you get over here that with the
help of these components or with the
help of
these uh virtual machines you can host a
host
a lot of binaries and a lot of
software's applications as such on this
one so it could be like you can
use these three virtual machines as a
different different environment
so a single server you have split up
into three environments machine one
you can use it as an kind of a dev
environment machine two you can use it
like a test environment and machine
three you can use it like
a prod environment or a pre-prod so this
really helps you to
uh have most out of your infrastructure
now earlier we used to have only one
server because we are using
physical uh machines but now we are
talking about virtual machines so here
we have got like different different set
of resources
uh being utilized and uh we can have
multiple virtual machines created
and that's a very good benefit also you
can think about like
okay i have just pay i'm just paying for
a cost of one server
and instead of that i'm getting three
different environments you can have it
like as an environment you can have it
like three different applications
deployed
so it's completely up to you like how
you are
going to perform the customization there
but it's
all something which can handle it at the
level of virtualization that's the main
focus
which we are trying to explain over here
right and like have i have already
explained over here
hypervisor is something which is going
to deploy
to see like how the specific
modifications and the changes can be
uh really deployed over here in this
case
right so this is a very important thing
to be considered because it's uh
something which where we will be able to
see like how
we can go for the overall implementation
of
this complete virtualized environment
here
right so now the next thing is that we
have got like hypervisor also configured
in two ways
you can have a hypervisor type one which
is a kind of
hypervisor which is available there for
example hyperkit for mac os hyper-v for
windows and kvm for linux
so this is something which is available
there for some couple of operating
systems which we have
commonly like windows mac os and linux
so there we can install
these type one kind of hypervisors there
so these are actually deployed on top of
the host operating system
then we have got like uh the type two
which is again
a little bit more complex hypervisors
now these are like
vmware and the virtualbox these
also provides you an additional features
like uh the
taiwan uh hypervisors are a little bit
uh limited there because they are just
trying to give you a flavor of virtual
machines
but if you are looking forward for a
kind of a production environment
or a kind of a real environment so in
that case the
type 2 infrastructure or type 2
hypervisor makes more sense for you in
that situation
so depending on the situations and
depending on the utilization
the selection between the type 1 or type
2 hypervisor can be decided there
right now uh let's see that uh you know
which situations we can use over here
now you can consider an example where
you are running like two applications
onto your server
and you want it to be done into complete
isolation
now this will basically require a two
operating system because
if you want to deploy the single
application on the same same operating
system or the same server machine
uh definitely they cannot be hosted
isolated there
so the only thing only reason why we can
have a
complete or total isolation is by
a splitting by having two different
guest operating systems there
so in that case only you can go for a
true
isolation on this case right so
this is the main benefit like you know
you can have
different environments created onto the
virtual environments
and uh you can have a great uh total
isolated environment and that's the
biggest benefit so you save the cost
you have saved the infrastructure you
have uh made the uh particular
maintainers easy
on top of that you made the proper a
true isolation for each and every
environment
so these are the main thing which is
being done by the hypervisor
so let's go ahead with the benefits of
hypervisor again one by one
cost efficient that's totally correct
because when we talk about hypervisor
it's
just telling that we are converting the
physical machines or michigan
physical servers in case of virtual
machines so which means
as per the previous diagram we were
converting a single machine into three
different virtual machines so you're
getting most out of your infrastructure
and at the same time that reduces the
cost also
now rather than going for three
different servers you're just using the
single server as in three virtual
machines
to come up with that environment so
that's the reason why it's
a kind of a cost efficient over here
flexibility that's great you have got a
create flexibility over here
in order to work with how the
maintenance of these virtual machines
can be done
you want to create the virtual machines
you want to delete the virtual machines
you want to do the stop start all that
activities you can actually do it
with the help of hypervisor here so
that's a great flexibility which we get
or which we
are getting from the hypervisor here
portability
these virtual machines which we are
creating in vmware it's not like i
cannot
use it in another system if i have the
vmware into one machine and i i have
another virtual machine vmware in
another environment i could literally
use the existing virtual machines there
also
so it helps me to save my time because i
don't have to rebuild my virtual
machines again and again
i can easily port it from one
environment to another environment
so i can do a clone also like i have got
one virtual machine
and i want to clone it like into five
six virtual machines i can do
that also so it it can be extended to
any level so these are all possibilities
only possible by the hypervisor
easy setup of maintainers a single
software maintaining all the activities
all the calls between the physical and
the virtual environment
so you don't have to do any kind of uh
maintainers as such over there
the backup restoration all those
features are already there in the
hypervisor
better resource allocation so you are
using 100 utilization of your resources
and you are getting max out of your
existing resources so the wastage of
resources
is also quite less when we talk about
the hypervisor or the
virtualization here now what are the
different components which we get with
the virtualization like how exactly the
virtualization virtualization gets
into the work so we have got like three
components
cpu memory and storage
now what is the cpu all about so cpu is
something where exactly
um we are getting the cores the
internal process of the system so the
virtual machines when we create onto a
physical environment
so these cores actually got uh shared to
the virtual environment also
so hypervisor is capable of for taking
or
having a virtual cpu created out of this
physical cpu there but it's not like
that that if
you are having four four cores or four
cpu
you can create eight virtual machine of
one core each
it's not like that you cannot multiply
that the number of cores which you can
use for the virtual machine
should always be less than what you have
physically available there
so that's the true virtualization which
we are talking about
of course uh you know these cores can
actually be a shared across multiple
virtual machines because
uh let's say like i have got two cores
and i can
create three virtual machines so
definitely these two cores can be shared
across these three virtual machines but
you have to limit the number of codes
because it's not like you want to
expose your host operating system host
system and uh
you should be into the limits when you
allocate these whole
cores or these cpus and memories
right so uh the hypervisor is actually
taking all the requests from the
virtual environment and then it send it
to the cpu there so the communication
between the virtual machine and the host
is not direct in fact it's through the
hypervisor
now virtual machine is just a ramp in
the in case of the system
in case of the hardware terminologies
when we use the virtual machine it
actually requires certain
memory also so we can get it there from
the
host memory just like in cpu here also
the limit applies
so if we have the host machine of 8gb
ram
we could use closely to 6gb of ram over
there so that we can have 102gb
left out for the host environment also
so we should not be compromising the
host environment
the number of virtual machines which we
can create on a particular server or a
piece of hardware
is also limited by the resources which
is allocated physically there
so that's something which we need to
take care on that so the
memory size is available there so you
can accordingly see like what kind of
resources you have
and then according to that you can
allocate it to the virtual machine so
you need to be careful about that how
many resources you actually
allocate to a specific virtual machine
there so
that should always be in a particular
limit and this is something which
we can actually modify whenever we feel
we can modify it also
right so that's the main reason that's
the main resource component which is
available there
which we can use then we have the
storage uh
ultimately after cpu and memory it comes
the storage also
so we have uh this as in different
storage devices which we can use with
the virtualization with the virtual
machines here
so uh using the uh vmware or
any other kind of hypervisor which
you're using you can actually manage the
storage also like what where exactly you
want to store these files or
you want to uh you know consume the
which which file system you want to
consume
so all those things we can actually
assign we can configure over there
and in fact like if you want to increase
or if you want to decrease the uh
specific size so that also we can do
there now there are some couple of uh
extensions which is available there now
these extensions may differ from
different
hypervisor which you're using so vdi
vhdx then we have got vmdk then we have
got like hdd
these are the different uh uh kind of
files extensions which is available
there when we talk about
the storage like where exactly the
virtual machines are getting stored
so these are getting stored in these uh
different different subsequent
extensions of the files here
so these are the different components
which is available there and uh
of course uh depending on different
hypervisors these configurations or
these
parameters may change over a period of
time but uh it's something which we can
see
like how these things can be a really
configured here
we are going to talk about like how we
can create a new virtual machine with
the help of vmware hypervisor
vmware workstation and also we're going
to talk about like if you have an
existing virtual machine
how we are going to do that clone
activity over there so this is the
official page of vmware where we can
download the vmware workstation 16
player here
now you can have this uh particular
software for linux and windows
platform both there so let's go for the
windows platform so i have already got
this uh installed over here so you can
see like in my downloads
it's going to show me like this player
is available there so it's close to 250
mb package which is available there
and all we need to do is like we need to
install this package as such
so i'm going to just open this installer
here
so it's going to be installed into my
system so once the installation is done
i will be able to have this specific uh
hypervisor
over here installed and then i can use
it for implementing the virtualization
into my system
so all i need to do is like i need to
just install this software
it may take a little bit more time
because it's in a heavy software which
is there
and it's doing a lot of installations
components there
so that's what it's happening there and
uh
apart from the installation over here in
this case like
apart from installing this uh particular
hypervisor of vmware software
virtualization software i also have to
uh
go ahead with the installation of an iso
image i and
a kind of image file i require whatever
operating system like if you want to go
for a windows operating system
deployment
or you want to go for ubuntu linux any
kind of platform if you feel like you
want to install so in that case you have
to
actually go ahead with the particular
installer so
uh that is something which we are
looking forward and we are trying to see
like how
uh we can download that the iso image
if it's windows you can download it from
windows website if it is
ubuntu centos anywhere you can do it so
what i'm going to do is like i'm going
to
download a specific small a kind of
tiny linux over here which will be very
easy for us to do the installation
i could easily go for ubuntu and those
kind of iso or image files also
but they will take a like a lot of time
for us to do it
and uh for this demo purpose we can
start with the tiny linux
and we can go for that customized
operating system but
when we actually require the
implementation when we feel like we want
to go for
a real implementation at that moment of
time we can go for the image like ubuntu
and all that stuff but it's all the same
only the kind of setup which you are
looking for
it's all the same only so my installer
is done
for the uh particular vmware so let's
see like
how we can download the ese file so
i can go for an installer like i can
download the image file for my tiny
linux
so now i'm going to download the
tiny linux iso file so this is the
website
which is available there now the tiny
core linux micro linux there are
different names which is available there
right
so you have multiple links which is
available there
from which you can actually download it
right so it's a basic a very
small complete version which is
available there so you can just download
it right and this is also this is the
official page which is there for tiny
core linux this is the
distributor link which is available from
which where you can download this one
so let's go ahead and let's download
this iso file so core
tiny core core plus there are different
kind of images which is there so
i'm just going for the uh tiny core
linux over here
um it's just a kind of uh version which
is available there which is having a
little bit
in like medium level of executables
available so
that's what i'm going to download so
it's actually there um you can see like
it's having a size of
20 mb alone that's the only size which
is available there so which means like
we will be able to
easily download it and uh get it on port
it onto our virtual machine here
so let's open the vmware meanwhile so
that i can go for the basic
configurations when i want to do that so
let's go with that
so i have opened the workstation 16
player so i'm going for the
free non-commercial use over here
otherwise if you have a license you can
go with that
i'm just going for this login here so
this is the
application which comes up over here
right so let me maximize it
so here you can actually create a
virtual machine you can open an existing
virtual machine also if for some reason
you got the virtual machine already
built up and
you want to import it over here you can
simply open it up there
right so i'm going to just uh create
a a new virtual machine here very simple
options
go to the player then file and the new
virtual machine here
now in this case you just have to
provide the iso image so i have already
downloaded it
now so i can just go with the particular
downloads option over here the tiny core
this is the iso image which is available
there now it could be a possibility
since it's a very small compressed one
so vmware may not be able to load it up
but the whole idea is like we just
require an iso image that can be ubuntu
or that can be anything there
now ubuntu will take a lot of time
because it's more than 1gb of
size so i'm just trying with the basic
iso image so that
we can actually get started uh much
faster over here in this one so
which operating system is this one so
this is like a linux operating system
which is available there
and uh we can see
into our options here uh if anything
related to tiny linux is available there
but if it's not there
so we can just select for the ubuntu 64
that's what we can select and we can say
like next
whatever the version you have like if
you are going for the specific one
virtual machine you can select the size
accordingly now here we were talking
about the disk size so i'm just giving
620 gb because that's a maximum size i
don't have to worry about
uh the particular size there 20 gb is
more than sufficient
if you feel like you want to create a
single file a single disk file for the
complete virtual machine you can just
select with this one
if you want to split it in multiple
files so that it would be easy for you
to
uh you know it provides a better
efficiency and if
in future you want to transfer the files
from one system to another that will
also be much easier
so depending on the situation you can
see like whether you want to go for a
single file or you want to go for
multiple files
and uh the customizations like i said uh
in this one the course
everything is available there so we are
allocating like 2gb
but you can see that there is a maximum
recommended memory which is available
there because my system is having like 6
gb
sorry 8 gb of ram so it's saying that
till 6.1 you should be going for that
particular memory because if we
say 8gb then 8gb means like your host
machine is also compromised
so the maximum recommend memory is 6 gb
now the recommended memory is 2 gb so
that's what we are trying to use here
and the processor definitely we have
like
32 cores which is available there so i
can actually use
like whatever the cores i want i feel i
can use that according to my
uh particular configuration so i can
actually use it accordingly
and uh if you want to enable the
virtualization cpu all these couple of
options are there
then iso image you have already
configured it like uh if you feel like
you can change it you can change it also
uh the network is there you got the
bridge host only
there are different uh network which is
available there usually bridge
connection uh will help you to
replicate uh the you know the connection
so it will directly get connected to the
physical network and
you will be able to you know share the
aspects like you can get the internet
activated and it's all going on in that
part mode there
so these are some couple of options
which is available they're using which
you will be able to
uh component like you can add it you can
configure it
if you feel like you want to add any one
of the uh hardware type which is not
being covered
that also you can do here right so i'll
just have to say close because this is
the configuration which i'm looking for
but pretty much it picked up the
decent uh basic configuration so i can
just go ahead with the finish part
and now if i feel like i want to edit it
i can do that but i can just start the
play button
to get the particular virtual machine
started
right so as you can see like it's just
downloading some couple of vmware tools
for linux so i can just say like
download and install
so these are some vmware tools which is
required now these tools are actually
used when you are dealing with the
virtual machine so at that moment of
time
these tools are required here now in
this one you have a multiple options
you can see like a boot tiny core
you want to use the boot core which is
only the command line interface
so these couple of options are available
there but i think
it's going to wait for close to 40 50
seconds it's already passed like 10 50
seconds
so after some time it will automatically
go for boot tiny core
but if i can just click on this window
inside and press
enter it will start proceeding with that
uh tiny core here right and if you feel
like you want to come
out of this so you have to do like
control alt like it's
hovering over here so right now you are
able to see like
my cursor is inside there but if you
want to go for control
alt then you will be back onto the host
machine
so when you click inside you will not be
able to you see my cursor is not going
outside this window it's limited over
here
so if you press ctrl alt then only you
will be able to see your cursor back
here
right and uh you can go into the
full maximize mode uh again control all
to come out
right and uh this is the particular
window which is coming up for you so let
this
uh tools installation okay it's already
going on so let it
get completed so these are some tools
which is getting installed
so that it will became very easy for you
to interact with the virtual machine so
for that purpose this is getting
installed
now um you can do a lot of work uh from
the power you can actually shut down it
you can restart it you can stop it all
that stuff you can do it
any removable devices if you have so
that you can over the fly can disconnect
it you can see like
you can disconnect over here right and
you want to
make it uh like a full screen you want
to uh you know do any kind of
virtual machine settings like here you
will be able to see like all these
settings you can again recover it
so these are some couple of options
which is available there now inside this
one so you have the options here like in
the bottom one you have the exit option
editor control panel then apps
run program mount tool terminal so
terminal is there
so you can see like it's a little bit uh
different terminal which you're getting
but of course like it's more than
sufficient for you to do that so
you can run some couple of uh components
here
now i can
now the output is very small here
because of this
particular one but it's actually being
used like it's using a specific
size of the file system which is being
allocated to this one
and uh this is where my operating system
is
basically being used over here in this
case right
so that's how the uh commands are going
to work
um it's it's going to execute some
couple of commands some
executions some commands may not be
available there so
you may have to execute that so that's
how it it it happens over there
right now if i have to come out control
alt same
and i'll just go here say that uh
let me stop it up so i can just
shut down this virtual machine here
and once this is done so i have to have
open the vmware player again to get it
on there
so this is what we have got over here in
this one this is a
kind of virtual machine which is
available there so again i can edit the
configurations
processor hard disk everything is
available there
right so if you see there's a very
important aspect about this one that the
maximum size which is
being allocated is 20 gb now it's not
like the complete 20 gb
is being allocated uh yes 2.6 mb is
being allocated right now the current
size
so gradually it will be increasing up to
20 gb but yes it's something
which is available and we can now see
like how exactly we can
uh you know what amount of size is being
utilized and what is being
used over here right and
this is just a virtual machine you can
have
multiple virtual machines which you can
create here so it's just a matter of
one virtual machines or 20 mutual
machines you can just have it all
available there
and these are the different prefaces
which is available there which you can
perform
and you can go ahead with that right you
can delete uh this one completely from
the
specific uh file system here so if you
feel like you want to completely wipe
out from the file system so that also
you can do here
so these are the different options which
is possible over here just to see like
how exactly we can go ahead with this
implementations all together right again
in the file you have all these options
which is available there
and uh you can also go for the
preferences which is available there
like how what are the different options
which is
being provided over here in this case so
that's a mechanism
how exactly we work with the virtual
machines
creations we can manage it and we can
get it
implemented all together right so that
was all about
the uh specific virtualization and
virtual machine
how we can make use of these components
as such so
that's it for this guys thanks
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here